[Music]
breaking news tonight Via Rail suspends
service across Canada the pipeline
protests grind things to a halt as
Ottawa says it will meet with pipeline
protesters but there's a catch
astonishing about-face first they denied
it
now Toronto police have copped up to
using a controversial facial recognition
tool the dramatic spike in kovat 19
cases put into context we need to be
cautious when drawing conclusions plus
the new effort to stop the spread inside
a cruise ship and new threat they cannot
be allowed to be seen the plight for
rhinos that's already happening to
humans
local national would Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with breaking
news Via Rail has now canceled all
commuter train service across Canada
because of the ongoing blockades sea and
rail also shut down its network in
eastern Canada protestors who joined
indigenous leaders opposed to a natural
gas pipeline in BC have been causing
major disruptions the prime minister
says he's hoping for a resolution as
soon as possible obviously the situation
we're following very closely but
obviously we're a country the rule of
law and we'll need to make sure that
those laws are followed the federal
government says it's ready to meet with
the elders but as abigail Beeman reports
the offer comes with a call to end the
blockades activists staged a sit-in at
the BC Attorney General's Office in
Vancouver until that happened one staff
member seemed upset her boss commenting
from the BC legislature still shut down
to the public due to protesters we've
been able to accommodate different
protests but where the line is is
obviously anything in relation to the
safety of my staff the BC government
along with Ottawa have accepted a
request to meet with hereditary chief
supposed to the coastal gasoline
pipeline but call for an end to the CN
Rail blockade in northern BC I'm hopeful
it may help and they helped the
situation in Ontario federal Indigenous
Services Minister Mark Miller offered to
meet with the Mohawk community but in an
email asked them to remove the rail
barricade as soon as possible
calling it a highly volatile situation
saying he's concerned about safety
colonial politicians like Mark Miller
turning the situation around like as if
we're the ones that are being violent
you can ask in you are lying you're
manipulating you're turning the
situation around you're gaslighting us
this BC indigenous MLA says protests
across the country aren't actually
helping indigenous people know they're
on
formed early getting 1% of the story in
terms of a small group of people
protract Chiefs in one area of the
pipeline nobody's talking about the 99%
of the First Nation communities that
extensively reviewed and investigating
these projects for the benefit of their
own communities now it's time for what's
owed in people to handle this issue by
themselves as for whether the federal
government may step in to get things
moving the conversation is really
ongoing but no answer from the
Agriculture Minister who says she knows
farmers especially are impacted Abigail
Beeman global news Ottawa the blockades
are hurting the Canadian economy rail
passengers can't go anywhere and freight
trains are sitting idle Ottawa is giving
indigenous groups space to protest but
as Eric Sorenson reports pressure is
mounting from the business community to
end the disruption at first all eyes
were on the blockades small acts of
defiance
but the impact now is mushrooming
through the Canadian economy by the hour
tens of thousands of rail passengers
have been affected mainly in the busy
corridor from southern Ontario to Quebec
and what's coming now a massive blow to
freight transportation trucks being held
up at ports on both coasts and rail cars
sitting idle in an industry that moves
more than 300 billion dollars worth of
goods per year from manufacturing to oil
products service stations could run low
on gasoline and propane deliveries are
falling behind nothing is moving right
now and parts of Ontario Quebec and
Atlantic Canada is starting to feel that
the inventories are getting lower the
agriculture sector coming off setbacks
in trade and an earlier cien rail strike
could now see canola wheat and other
grains stuck in elevators caught in the
middle of an economic chain reaction
farmer Daryl France ooh the simple fact
is we don't get paid if we don't get
paid we can't pay our bills we hope that
the difference you know groups involved
will find a way to understand each other
agriculture minister Mary Claude bibo
says in the spirit of reconciliation
Ottawa is trying to balance the concerns
of indigenous protests
with the growing economic impact today
Bebo's suggested Ottawa can't sit back
indefinitely we have to give a little
bit time to the different parties to to
you know have a discussion and find a
solution but at a certain point we have
to do something hoping isn't enough we
need action on the part of the federal
government this business leader says
Canada could soon see layoffs at home
and repercussions abroad if we're not
seen as as dependable suppliers if we
can't get our products to market this
means that companies and countries will
start looking elsewhere one survey found
slightly more Canadians oppose the
protests than support them though the
opposition may grow as the economic
impact is felt and pressure mounts on
Ottawa to get Canadian goods and
passengers back on track
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto the
Toronto Police Service has made a
disturbing admission officers use secret
facial recognition technology from
Clearview AI
to dig up sensitive personal information
based on nothing more than photos they
were ordered to stop using the
controversial tool last week but just
last month the police denied using it at
all Jeff's simple reports I'm appalled
that this check is being used that
reaction from Ontario's former privacy
commissioner after Toronto police
admitted to using facial recognition
technology from Clearview AI the
company's app can cross-reference a
person's image against a database of
billions of photographs scraped from
social media and millions of other
websites without consent the American
firm CEO defends his tech on
constitutional grounds but there is also
a First Amendment right to public
information Clearview AI sparked
controversy last month in the United
States after the New York Times revealed
the tech was already being used to make
arrests following those revelations
Global News asked Toronto police whether
Clearview AI software it was being used
here the answer not anymore
in a statement a spokesperson said that
some members of the service began using
Clearview AI in October with the intent
of informally testing this new and
evolving technology the chief directed
that its use be halted immediately upon
his a
- and the order to cease using the
product was given on February 5th in
other words the tech was used for months
without the police chiefs knowledge
I am surprised because you would think
that something this invasive without any
notice or consent without a warrant
without anything is the access by police
forces other police forces such as
Calgary's use facial recognition
software that compares a person's image
to their internal police mugshot meaning
they can only use images of suspects who
have already been photographed by police
but some such as Ontario's provincial
police force refuse to say whether it
uses the clear view AI app the company's
own website contains a quote from an
unnamed Canadian Detective Constable
calling Clearview hands down the best
thing that has happened to victim
identification in 10 years within a week
and a half we made eight identifications
of either victims or offenders this is
the technology that snuck in through the
cracks in our regulations through the
cracks in our laws some of the world's
biggest tech companies are now demanding
the clear view AI stop using their
social media platforms a number of
class-action lawsuits have also popped
up and the Toronto Police say that they
will now work with Ontario's privacy
commissioner to determine whether the
software is an appropriate tool for
investigations Robin Jeff sample in
Toronto the u.s. is adding new charges
in its case against Chinese tech giant
huawei the company is accused of a
decades-long plot to steal trade secrets
and intellectual property from rival
companies in the US prosecutors say in
some cases while way gave employees
bonuses to steal from competitors Huawei
and its chief financial officer mung
Wong geo are already facing criminal
charges of fraud and violating US
sanctions against Iran and North Korea
in December 2018 the RCMP arrested ma at
Vancouver International Airport on an
extradition request from the US the
death toll in the corona virus outbreak
continues to soar tonight according to
Chinese media more than 1,400 people
around the world have died the vast
majority in China more than 65 thousand
cases
are being reported again most are in
China it's a significant jump because
according to public health experts
there's been a change in the way cases
and whom a province are being confirmed
before authorities were only counting
cases confirmed by specialized testing
kits now they're also including cases
diagnosed using other clinical tests
such as CT scans so we're not dealing
from what we understand with the spike
in cases of 14,000 on one day to an
extent this is an artifact of the
reporting and and we are working with
our colleagues in China our team they
are working very hard to see exactly how
many days and weeks and how those
numbers are spread out across those days
and weeks the whu-oh says outside China
covered 19 cases are not rising
dramatically Japan has recorded its
first death though and on board a cruise
ship in Yokohama the virus is still
spreading crystal commencing reports the
lineup of ambulances near the diamond
princess tells the story new cases of
kovat 19 continue to infect those on
board the cruise ship docked in Japan
now has 218 cases including 12 Canadians
efforts are underway to move older
passengers especially those in
windowless cabins to isolation centers
elsewhere the situation on the vessel
has the attention of the World Health
Organization outside the cases on the
diamond Princess cruise ship we're not
seeing a dramatic increase in
transmission outside China dr. Michael
Ryan expressed concern for those on
board noting a very different situation
for the ship docked in Cambodia where no
illness has been detected so this is a
heavy night
more than 1,400 jubilant Western
passengers are now preparing to make
their way home Angela Jones recorded
this message from the president of
Holland America I'm sure you'll have
some good stories to tell when you reach
your final destination home so again I
want to extend my sincere and heartfelt
thank you for countries in one territory
previously turned away the ship because
of fears about the virus in some kovat
19 causes cold like symptoms
others developed serious respiratory
tract problems china appears to be
responding with force more than 1,000
military medics were deployed to Hubei
province and the epicenter Wuhan the
head of the Communist Party in who Bay
has been removed from his post the
latest Chinese official to be fired
meanwhile the WH Show is calling for
data information on the virus potential
drugs and its origins understanding
where the sources have become very
important it's operationally very
important and for the future it's very
important the WH OHS expert team in
China led by Canadian doctor Bruce
Aylward is already on the ground
additional workers are set to arrive to
support them this weekend crystal good
man Seng Global News London
Bombardier is getting out of the
commercial aviation business the Quebec
based plane and train maker is selling
its remaining stake in the a 220
jetliner for nearly 600 million dollars
u.s. the company has transferred its
shares to Airbus and the Quebec
government as it moves to merge from
more than nine billion dollars in debt
under the deal Airbus will own 75% of
bombard A's commercial aviation business
the Quebec government 25% Bombardier is
reporting a loss of more than 1.6
billion dollars for 2019 Airbus says the
deal secures more than three thousand
aerospace jobs in Quebec former
Conservative cabinet minister John Baird
says he will not be seeking the federal
party leadership his announcement ends
the speculation he would enter the race
so far just three candidates are
officially in the running
former cabinet colleagues Peter MacKay
and Aaron O'Toole plus Toronto lawyer
Leslie Lewis Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau has concluded a week-long trip
to Africa his visit was part of a
Canadian campaign to get support from
African nations for Canada's bid to win
a Security Council seat our chief
political correspondent David akin has
been traveling with the Prime Minister
so David did Trudeau secured any votes
for that seat well it's impossible to
say no with any certainty it is after
all a secret ballot on June 17th at the
UN and countries are known to change
their minds but what we do know is the
diplomats working on the Security
Council campaign tell me that they feel
more upbeat now than they did a week ago
the only African leader to come right
out and say that Canada should be on a
Security Council with Senegal's
President Macky Sall he did that
Wednesday at the beginning of Trudeau's
two-day trip to this West African
country Trudeau has told African leaders
Canada would use a seat on the Security
Council to among other things advance
gender equality Trudeau also says Canada
would help African nations fight climate
change and keep oceans clean being on
the Security Council is a further way of
us to have an either greater impact in
standing up for the principles we
believe in but Canada is in tough
against competing bids by Ireland and
Norway they and other critics of
Canada's bid have been reminding African
voters that Canada spends a relative
pittance on foreign aid indeed Norway
spends relatively speaking five times as
much something Norway's Prime Minister
Erna Solberg was saying as she to
campaign for votes at last weekend's
African Union summit our difficulty now
is a bit that we and Canada have a same
approach but maybe we've been a most
steady partnership for the
multilateralism for a long time
Solberg and others argue Canada's
commitment to the continent has been
inconsistent meanwhile Trudeau's
political opponents are hammering him
for not being home to deal with those
protests and economic turmoil but Joe
not coming back anytime soon next week
he's traveling again this time to
Barbados where he will pitch Caribbean
in Latin American countries for Canadian
UN Security Council votes
David akin Global News Dakar controversy
grips the US Justice Department coming
up the allegations it's doing a favor
for the president and one of his
confidants there is growing alarm
tonight that US President Donald Trump
is using his office as an instrument for
personal vendettas the Justice
Department is pushing for a shorter
sentence for Trump's longtime friend and
former campaign associate Roger stone
he's been convicted of lying and
obstructing the Russia investigation
who's Jackson Prosecco a self-proclaimed
dirty trickster from the era of
Watergate Roger stone really made a name
for himself in the age of Trump after
being convicted of lying to protect the
president they treated Roger stone very
badly this week Trump openly complained
about the lengthy sentence stone now
faces for obstruction and witness
tampering nine years for doing something
that nobody even can define what he did
and soon after the Justice Department
headed by Trump's Attorney General Bill
Barr overruled prosecutors and asked for
stone to face less prison time this is
an abuse of power that the president is
again trying to manipulate federal law
enforcement to serve his political
interest for government lawyers have
resigned in protest renewing accusations
that the Attorney General is serving the
interests of Trump and not the American
people I want to thank the Justice
Department for seeing this bar responded
by telling the President to stay out of
it I cannot do my job here at the
department with a constant background
commentary that that undercuts me
I have never obstructed justice in the
decades after Richard Nixon and
Watergate presidents went out of their
way to avoid the slightest perception of
interference in the justice system not
so in the Trump era where the Attorney
General has positioned himself to do the
president's bidding I think we are
saying
mantling of the post-watergate reforms
like nothing we've seen in decades stone
now awaits his lighter sentence and is
holding out hope for a full presidential
pardon the fear in Washington is that
the president learned a lesson after his
impeachment acquittal that he can move
the wheels of justice to protect his
friends and prosecute his enemies with
impunity
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
still ahead a volcano erupts at the
crack of dawn lighting up the skies in
Mexico
that thunderous boom rang out in Mexico
indicating the Popocatepetl volcano
erupted a webcam capture the night skies
light up as the crater spewed lava and
an ash column nearly 5000 feet high the
volcano is 80 kilometres from Mexico
City and one of the most active in the
country no one was hurt but a volcanic
ash advisory has been issued one of
Antarctica's fastest shrinking glaciers
has lost an iceberg about 350 square
kilometers in size that's about as big
as Las Vegas Antarctica stores about 70
percent of the world's fresh water in
the form of snow and ice if it were all
to melt sea levels would rise by 50 to
60 metres with that will take many
generations and scientists have recorded
Antarctica's hottest temperature ever a
high of 20 point 7 degrees Celsius at
Seymour Island just days before a
research station on the northern tip of
the continent logged a record 18 point 3
degrees Celsius the result these
dramatic images show a bear and nearly
iceless landscape in the northern region
up next resistant rhinos the new threat
facing the animal on the brink of
extinction
poachers have pushed the black rhino to
the edge of extinction but the horned
animals are now facing a new threat they
appear to have become unexpected
casualties of antibiotics a study out of
Kenya finds rhinos are developing
alarming levels of resistance to the
drugs Mike Armstrong reports there are
only 29 thousand rhinos left in the
world officially they're classified as
critically endangered their main threat
has been poachers hunting them for their
tusks but a group of scientists found a
new threat antibiotic resistance and
that's a problem for veterinarians
caring for endangered rhinos they cannot
be allowed to be sick and if they are
sick they need to be treated the group
worked out of Kenya's rumen National
Park it analyzed the fecal matter of
black rhinos so here we're seeing a lot
of a woody part yes in sort of a
branching in the lab scientists pulled
ecoli out of the Rhino stool samples
they analyzed its resistance to eight
common antibiotics and compared that to
human results what they found is black
rhinos living in the wild and humans had
similar resistance to four of the
antibiotics and in two of the others the
black rhinos had more resistance than
humans we need to consider our handling
how we handle this animal now the cause
isn't known it could be transmission
from conservationists or contamination
in a river but antibiotic resistance is
a massive issue a Canadian group raised
alarm bells this past fall it found that
in 2018 in Canada 26% of bacterial
infections were resistant to treatment
but predicted that number could hit 40
percent by 2050 the Rhino study shows
the misuse and overuse of antibiotics by
humans is affecting other species even
in the wild as well Mike Armstrong
Global News that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is dildo Newfoundland and
Labrador we would love to see your part
of this country so email your pictures
to viewers at global national comm thank
you for watching and I'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]